هي لغه كل الايام بالنسبه لابنائها هذا
الوطن الكبير
يستعملونها كل يوم يعلمها الكبار للصغار
وتحدث بها اكثر من 300 مليون شخص في هذا
العالم انها اللغه العربيه التي احتفت يوم
امس 18 من ديسمبر بيومها العالمي ويحتفل
العرب بها لمده اسبوع كامل فيما يعرف
باسبوع اللغه العربيه نحن سنجرب معكم
قراءه هذه الابيات العجيبه من اللغه
العربيه
نبدا معكم في البيت الاول
وقبروا حربا بمكان قفر وليس قرب قبر حرب
قبر القبر هنا يعني المكان الخالي الذي لا
شيء حوله وتدللت البيت ان القبر لا شيء
حوله فهو في مكان بعيد لوحده
الم الم الم الم بدائه ان ان ان انو اوانه
فتى فتن في فتاه فتاه وبات بسبب الفتاه
فتاه اظن هذا البيت اشهر من البيتين
السابقين لكن مترادفه فيه كثيرا وهنا كان
الاعجاز والابداع الادبي صادق صديقا صادقا
في صدقه فصدق الصداقه في صديق صادق كذلك
هذا البيت هو الشاعر بسيط لكنه كثير
المترادفات
[موسيقى]
بدا بدا
او نانا
فتاه ومات بسبب فتاه في فتاه فتاه
بسبب الفتاه قبل حرب بمكاني قفر وليس قرب
قبر فتى في فتاه فتاه
في صدقه في صدقي
فصدق الصداقه في صديق صادق انا انا انا
اواني
وبات بسبب الفتاه
وليس قرب قبر حرب
الفتاه
وليس بقبر قبر
فتاه صادق صديق صادق في صدقه الصداقه في
صديق صادق
[موسيقى]